hey what's up beautiful babies uh
welcome to another episode of get close
i am your co-host gio and i'm bart and
today we have special guest mari i'm so
happy to have you here you guys may know
her from smosh she's a gamer she's a
dancer she's in everything you're like
in everything and right now you're like
doing acting right like you're going to
school for acting yeah um
okay so i want to go into all of it but
the first thing our first real
connection right here is we're dry ass
biggest people now yeah yeah we gotta
continuously put on the chapstick yeah
the humidifier is our best friend as i'm
smiling at you right now my my teeth are
dry so my lips are getting stuck that's
how [ __ ] dry it is
smiling what helped you make the move
because i feel like there's a ton of
people that you know move entertainment
fitness entrepreneurial whatever right
to l.a
and then i think for the last decade or
so or even more that was kind of the hot
spot
and then over the last two or three
years it's been like
and then people are like kind of going
other places what the hell was that what
was this
shaking things up yeah yeah
the foundation has been shook yeah and
then now people are leaving
and so it always feels like endearing
and familiar when like la peeps move
somewhere else together not that we
coordinated it yeah but it's like
you're there another one other one yeah
it was um i mean the pandemic did it i i
think that the pandemic for
for so many people including you know
myself and my husband like
so many things came a lot clearer where
it's like oh why are we still drinking
this kool-aid
of la where it's just like wait how much
do you pay for rent okay
that's astronomical but that's normal
right okay that's fine okay i do it too
and then it's like okay so we're in this
city that that
the infrastructure of like driving
around is an absolute hot mess but you
have to get to places within a certain
amount of time that's okay okay everyone
everyone's doing this yeah ten miles two
hours yeah totally normal yeah yeah
that's great i mean it's just like what
you think is normal um
got completely shuffled during the
pandemic um yeah this motion right there
yeah and so i think it became a lot
clearer that okay maybe we don't have to
be in the city in order to run our
businesses to continue doing what we're
doing and be successful and all that
stuff um but weren't you scared oh hell
yeah cause you know like i think like
when you're so comfortable someplace you
know especially because you're from the
bay right yep me and gio pretty much
born and raised in l.a were you born and
raised in cali too yeah okay yeah san
francisco area okay yeah like you my
whole life
everyone has come to california to visit
right i'm like come on over you know
come hang out in the best state of the
world
and then when you start going wait
do i want to move what the hell what's
going on mm-hmm it feels scary yeah do
you have family here or no
no not no family here um
but i do have friends out here that i
used to film with and filmed with in the
past and so we did our short film out
here uh with uh
these cinematographers who have a
youtube channel called is mohawk and so
they're like serious directors they're
serious cinematographers um and they're
out here the stunt team that we worked
with is out here and so i'm like okay i
have a little network a small hub here
of at least folks that that i can start
working with and i i wanted to work with
them more even when i was living in l.a
um
back to l.a
they would never like it's like filming
in la makes no sense now like the the
thought of like permitting wherever you
go yeah um
and it being so astronomically expensive
to do anything in l.a just like over
here
i don't know if you felt the same way
what's permitting out here because i
think in l.a
have you felt like like like vegas
people i feel like in general are like
don't put laws on us because
like we'll operate in a lawful way as
long as if you don't put rules on us and
so people will like you know do whatever
they do in the desert
as long as it's lawful and not they're
not hurting people but that like people
just like i don't know like
do whatever in the desert yeah
they're just not
that was my first taste of policing out
here i was driving and i i think the
crosswalk or something it's painted a
little bit either further i think it's a
little bit further away from where the
cars are supposed to stop from where i'm
what i'm used to in la because i think
the crosswalk is literally right there
where the the stop light is like the
corner yeah this one's a little bit
further away so i'm used to getting up
to the line so i'll drive up to the line
and then i look left and right and i'm
like a car length in front of everyone
else have you noticed that that they do
that here notice that okay it's going to
stick out maybe maybe i'm just a bad
driver i have noticed though that people
really follow school zones yes
and that to me like people actually
drive like 15 miles an hour
but yeah so i pulled up
i look over and there's a police officer
and i'm like holy [ __ ] this guy's going
to light me up and i'm like slowly
rolling back because no one's behind me
and i'm looking at him and he just looks
at me and he goes kind of like i know
you messed up it's cool and i'm like
whoa there's second chances over here
i'm so grateful that will never happen
again which i have happened a couple
more times but i'm still getting you
i don't feel like the police are out to
get me they're just here to make sure
everyone's cool yeah which is pretty
cool it does feel like such a chill
sort of like environment here and just
i don't know what it is about la i don't
know if it's just like the rat race and
everyone feels like they're on some sort
of hamster wheel but
it feels more chill here getting
together with people feels more chill i
mean coveted you know restrictions
otherwise but i don't know yeah it feels
nice um i think there was that study
that they did right where they had a
bunch of rats um in like kind of a
confined area and then after a while
like they started getting a little bit
rampant and then like i think they
started developing sort of like or
disorders right like where they started
like fighting each other and they
started getting super aggressive because
they just didn't have space anymore yeah
they did this study because like rats
exhibit a lot of social behaviors the
way that humans do
so they kind of wanted to see like how
rats would behave
what in the heezy i blame bart i know
i'm so sorry um they popcorn's done
they
they wanted to see like how rats would
behave in different settings so they
have one where it's like i don't know
like uh what they think is the
recommended square foot per rat
and everyone's just doing their thing
and go they say hi what they're like
pulling their whiskers or whatever the
hell they do you know going on how cute
that they're supposed to do
right there's food someone brings it to
the center everyone's sharing it
then they pack it
once they pack it over time you have
rats that are going on the corner
they're just rocking
like scratching like very anxious rats
then there's rats that see food and they
grab it they go hoard it they bury it
and then it's just like almost like a um
like hoarding of resources
very strange behavior that also is
reminiscent of what like metropolitan
cities look like you know and it's just
crazy to see like it's when it when
there's that kind of con congestion
it's not that humans aren't above it you
know which is pretty crazy yeah i think
it's probably an intrinsic quality that
we have never shaken and i don't think
we ever will that that sort of like
survival instinct and needing to yeah i
mean look at the toilet paper debacle in
2020 right like
strange strange behaviors happen that is
[ __ ] funny yeah okay i don't mean to
because we tend to do this quite a bit i
don't mean to talk [ __ ] on california i
absolutely [ __ ] love california born
and raised in california we all are
right yeah um it's just kind of
unfortunate that we had to leave but i
think it's what i'm also talking about
isn't just california it's like big city
yes like people in chicago new york
detroit i feel like there's like a very
similar
like once people get jam-packed and the
infrastruc and like i think the
population outgrows their infrastructure
it's it's almost feels like the like the
pants are bursting at the seams yeah you
even feel it lax versus burbank airports
true you know like the anxiety of lax
and the people working there the
day-to-day sort of feelings that they
have impacted on them like
as workers totally different in burbank
burbank's like yeah yeah
like you know open up your bags how's
your day going you're like i know you're
liking me how my day is going how's your
day going
exactly but i think that's something
cool about um i think that's cool about
a trait that people that are
um that are just pursuing something
different or something successful or or
um um just wanting a better life that
are down to see something and say okay i
love it
but it's not working for me it's not
conducive to the to the life that i want
to you know have in 5 10 15 20 years so
something needs to change and i think
that's really dope that you were one of
those people as well where you're like
okay wait a minute i see where i want my
life to be and i see that this is just
not the vibe i want so i'm just gonna
get up and go and that was something
that i um i saw from you from the very
first time i met you i don't know if you
remember but um the very first time we
met um that i can recall is at jk news
and then you were talking about how you
were working with small shop that time
but you were still living in norcal like
you were still living in san francisco
um but you gotta be like 2015 or
something forever again yeah that's
about right
and you were talking about how you would
like fly back and forth and you would
spend yeah and i was like that [ __ ]
blew my mind like i had never met anyone
that didn't see obstacles the way i had
seen them like i just figured like okay
if i need to make a living as f the
farthest i can imagine my little [ __ ]
rat brain going is maybe like
20 30 miles away from where i reside
right because then i'm thinking all my
other in life inconveniences kind of
like piling up on top of each other so
when i heard you say like yeah i'm just
gonna fly into la like what's the big
deal i was like mind blown and i
completely admired that about you dude
i mean thank you i i appreciate it i i
think that it's like
it's compacted with a lot of other
things where it was i was not ready to
completely
walk away from my other life which was
the bay area life which is ballet and
my career that i had built up since i
was like you know i mean i started
ballet when i was two not that i started
my career when i was two but you know it
was the only thing that i knew and it
was the only thing that felt like a sure
deal like a real
thing there's institutions like ballet
companies that exist that will give me
jobs is was my mentality so i'm like
well i can't walk away from this for an
internet job
um and so
it was my way of
gripping
white knuckled to the you know to that
old life and
dipping my toes into this new one that
kept growing and growing bigger and
bigger unexpectedly um
so i did what uh what what the only way
i know how to do it which is to just
have the show go on which is do
everything i can to
make both things happen how did the
concept of um
flying every single weekend
not make you say no
because that's tough i think for a lot
of people they'll be like [ __ ] that you
know
that's
great that's local i mean
to a certain degree it is because i
think it is my
quality of needing to please people and
that was at the root of it and you know
we were chatting very well a little bit
before we started recording but you know
it is coming to terms with why did i do
that
was it for me
and at the end of the day it is for me
because it built my career but why did
why did i do that as the first step
rather than say well
how can we work around it so that i'm
not flying every single week for two and
a half years so why did you do it
to to appease
my life and my lifestyle with ballet and
the companies that i worked with and
then to appease this new lifestyle of
the new company that i worked with and
so at that point it was you know making
sure i don't lose my job at the ballet
company and also not lose my job at defy
media and so it was like how do i make
everyone happy it is
lose sleep be tired still work work my
ass off and show up on time and be
peachy and it's like i don't know if
it's because i was wired that way young
from ballet of just like do whatever you
need to do to get the show going yeah
or if it is
just i was young and naive and it was
easy too
i mean it could be all of that two and a
half years is crazy yeah yeah and we're
talking how old are you at that point
like in your early 20s maybe no mid-20s
i was yeah like 26 27 yeah i feel like
we got to give ourselves a little bit
more grace right because it's like
you're going from becoming
a teenager where it's like hormones are
all wild your body's changing like um
you're not a baby but you're not an
adult and now you're going into now
after that like you graduate high school
now you're you're more so an adult but
you're still an adolescent um you're
still figuring your [ __ ] out like i feel
like the 20s should be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show yeah you know what i mean like i
feel like um [ __ ] show meaning like your
life's all over the place i mean throw
yourself at whatever it is you need to
regardless if it's pleasing yourself
pleasing other people like i get it like
we were just kids we were a lot of us
were raised to like do what our parents
tell us to do especially yes and figure
it out yeah especially for race
traditionally right and women for some
reason i don't know how your family
structure is but like um at least for
mexicans it's like when i was growing up
it always felt like i was a second-class
citizen to the man you know so when like
my mom was was teaching me to be classy
or not sit this way with like my crotch
showing it's like what are people going
to think you got to be a lady you got to
be classy so you're really trying to
like check off all these boxes from like
your parents and then kind of follow
what your friends are doing because
their parents kind of told the same
thing but then you think that they're
successful so i feel like
our lives kind of tend to be a little
bit all over the place in the 20s and i
think that's okay yeah i think i think
you're totally right i mean i think for
the first 18 years you're in a confined
space if you're in a you know more or
less traditional home situation you have
some sort of parental guidance
and probably a lot of walls around you
and so you're you're functioning as a
human and you're learning things but
you're really out there from 18 plus or
you know maybe even 22 plus once you're
out of college
and then you're out in the real world
and you don't have these walls around
you anymore and you're trying to figure
things out yeah the the the timing for
what i think humans should be doing with
their lives or what we should have
figured out is still within like the
confines of like when people used to
like
die at the age of 50. yeah you know and
it's like we're in a lot longer yeah
we're having kids at what 12 13 14
people are getting married around that
time like not even 50 years ago yeah
that's true people were getting married
like a 15 14 yeah
and it's like we're still
working off of that structure of like oh
yeah you better have your things figured
out at least by 20 because you should
probably be popping out kids by 25.
you're a mother by then and by by 30 you
should probably have like two or three
kids and a house and a house oh you
gotta have a house yeah you better have
a house and then and then you
you retire and then you die you know
it's like that used to be that time
that's crazy yeah but we're not that
anymore and so we kind of need to like
learn to adjust that timeline yeah i
think you're right 20s you should be a
hot mess and figuring things out
yeah when you're bouncing back and forth
um
do you come from like a super
traditional asian type family where you
have to experience i mean uh explain to
your parents
what this internet thing is and why you
have to fly
every single weekend
so my
i was in ballet so i think that that
already kind of like
broke the structure of what is
traditional
but ballet and my family is like that is
equivalent to being a doctor that is an
equivalent to being a lawyer i'm a
second generation dancer and it's like
it's my mom's entire being which is
ballet she's a dancer too oh yeah and
she was my teacher and my coach
that must have been so fun
it was like
at times it was like 80 coach 20 mom and
then it sometimes it would flip the
script and i'm like i don't know
which one it is right now i don't know
if to call you coach or to call you mom
sort of thing and so it was a lot of
now as an adult you know like
relearning what my childhood was and
being okay with it and like parsing out
things where i'm like okay that's not
okay
but i have to be okay with what it was
it's not okay but it's okay yeah you
know what's something that's like that
um i think that
understanding that
the way that i will
receive praise for what i do
in work
is not ever going to be what i expect or
need
from
from my parent
um and it's it's because in my mom's
mind you know like if i was if i found
the same level of success
in ballet that i have
with
with non-ballet things
it would be
the the type of praise that i would want
now but i realize that in her mind
that's not what she can give me
and i think that being okay with that
and understanding that that's not the
expectation and i can't expect that yeah
has given me a lot of peace yeah um but
at the same time i realized that
you know a parent
in in like the ideal way
should give their kid
praise for what the kid wants and wants
to do and how the kid wants to
to live their life but i can also
understand how difficult it is as a
parent you know i'm not a parent so i i
don't know yeah but
especially
especially
uh
raising kids at a time where we don't
have open conversations like this yeah
oh my gosh it's got it had to have been
so bonkers did she ever make you do
crazy [ __ ] like watch cartoons on your
tippy toes or something
oh i i mean yeah yeah i like that that's
how you think ballet works
i'm thinking like asian training of
ballet right like maybe you got to be
like this on your [ __ ] tippy toes and
you have to like i don't know like watch
cartoons or twirl three times before you
can eat food or something you want to
hear it okay so i would put pillows on
my feet and stick them underneath the
couch so that there's what like four
inches of clearing in the couch yeah to
shape my feet to point
and then
for the arches and so that would be for
feet training and then at night time i
would raise my feet how long are you in
there for
um for like two episodes of bobby's
world or something probably yeah yeah 40
minutes that's about right
yeah which which you like now with that
athlete training now like
big no no like you shouldn't be
stretching like that yeah in general
yeah yeah i would i would put books on
my knees and raise my legs so that my
legs would be more um hyper-extended
and like
learn how to do that and not learn but
make my body
conformed to it
um yeah just stretching all the time
when you talk to your friends at that
age about stuff like that
did it ever occur to you like this isn't
normal like they're just playing in the
front yard and i'm here with books on my
knees i think i always knew it wasn't
normal
but i also
never fought back no i don't think i
knew how to be like
like i i don't i don't want to do that
to my legs you know what i mean like i
had no no proof or anything like that to
be like well other kids do this or you
know like google search like well what
do other ballet dancers my age how did
they train at home is it is it you know
all day after school
oh maybe it's not normal you know and
yeah
it's just it your world becomes what you
know and i think without the resources
you just accept what it is and that was
all of us until a certain time in our
age right where it's like oh we have
outside resources to
to be able to what's the right way to
train your feet and knees then
i
i think in a lot of ways ballet is still
opposite of like so much of
what
should be normal for about for for a
body but also i think it it it shows
what is
possible for a body yeah which i think
is extraordinary it is um [ __ ] like
this move like an inch at a time without
the rest of your body jittery yeah it
just looks effortless it's nice what the
hell yeah i don't think people if you're
not so i did i'm not even going to try
to compare my ballet creator yours she's
a professional not even close no
um
but i did ballet and this is this sounds
like someone that goes like yeah i
played sports i played in junior high
and as soon as they say junior high
you're like
okay but it's the equivalent of that
you're talking to someone in the nba i'm
very much aware of it um but i i loved
ballet growing up and i did it for a few
years i got to the point where i was
like doing toe shoes and stuff but like
i didn't have any of that training
because um it was more of like a
neighborhood thing like like moms just
knew to put their kids in
extracurricular activities so boys went
to sports and girls did some sort of
dance whether then you guys didn't have
books at home so there's nothing that
you're not books at home you can't even
put on the knees is that a mexican joke
you son of a
[ __ ] um
or couches oh my gosh
oh he's talking [ __ ] um
but i was really passionate about it
growing up so i saw how extreme the
training was and like the diet is super
rigid like yeah they would say like oh i
see some jiggly something there like you
need to cut it down to like maybe eating
four peas and a [ __ ] chicken breast
is it [ __ ] wild
that was normal and okay yeah and it's
like it's still kind of like that now
for kids yeah like eight or nine are
like what are you eating dude they have
like the worst when you're a teenager
when your body is changing yeah and like
i i think for for like teenage girls you
don't know what your body's gonna look
like when it's in it's like womanly form
yeah because like before that you can be
a string bean and then after hormones
hit you're like oh this is a different
body yeah it's completely curved
and
boobs which is so opposite of what
ballet like constricts you to yeah um
yeah i mean i remember i had a student
at
18 she was like okay i'm really gonna do
ballet this is gonna be the the track
that i go on but she's cuban and like
her body is not it's bomb yeah
it is and so like in that moment she's
like all right i'm gonna get breast
reduction i'm gonna do everything to
like conform to it and she didn't go
with it
and now she's like she's a supermodel
now like she's like a model you know
it's like
you you just
i i think that it's so much of
do you listen to like
what what the box is and what what what
what it's always been and what you have
to conform to or do you say [ __ ] it and
like do you find your own way yeah i
think right now is like a time where
everyone's questioning it yeah i mean
it's it's it's the reason why you guys
have a [ __ ] room in your house you
know
and you have a podcasting place here
yeah like well you could you could work
the status quo and go to have a nine to
five or you can
get off the wheel and do something that
you want to do yeah at what point were
you like so it's like it was kind of
ingrained and that's all you kind of
knew ballet right so at what point were
you like huh there's options
uh
i think
i mean it was it was it wasn't immediate
because
so the way i see it
with ballet i feel like i it was it was
handed to me in the sense of like i was
trained before i knew what i was doing
yeah and my mom is your coach yes and so
by the time i was in you know like ready
to audition ready to to grab jobs i had
already had years of this training and
so in some ways i feel like i was handed
this golden like this silver spoon of
like training
with
coming on to digital my first step into
anything digital was with smosh and in
2010 they had 10 million subscribers
which back then was like it's
massive they already had an empire yeah
so the very first thing that i did and
for subsequently for like like two years
after that the the
one woman show that i made on that on on
smosh would hit like close to a million
every single time and so that was my
bar that i started with i was again i
feel like in so many ways handed this
golden opportunity
because i i was already
standing upon the empire that they built
you know and so
i
i think that
because the bar was already there
it wasn't this thing that felt like
like the grind that i feel like when
when you started from
scratch you know it felt like more of
like this responsibility of like having
this like
this torch now and being like oh [ __ ] i
gotta carry this and i better carry this
like
to to to uphold
what they have already built and so it
felt like more of like a responsibility
than this thing where like i scratched
and clawed and tooth i i learned how to
edit i learned how to speak in in front
of a camera like i learned all these
things from scratch but i didn't do the
work of
earning every view and earning all those
things in my mind you know i had to turn
an audience
and like it's weird because the the
first like i would say like
seven months worth of content that i put
on smosh
all have like 13 000 dislikes but the
dislikes tab is going on like but every
week
every week what were they so unhappy
about
that i was a girl on smosh yeah yeah and
you're probably new yeah yeah yeah if
you're i was you and i was the third
person on smosh and so it was like ian
and anthony and then this rando girl who
came on and it's like
i think every industry is is similar in
the sense of like when a woman is like
comes onto the scene people are like
well why is she there yeah right like
who does she sleep with to get there
yeah you know why why is she deserving
of this and so it became a thing of like
well whose girlfriend is she yeah
oh my god or bolts
you know
it was always the bolts where i'm like
oh yeah both yeah
it sounds like a discussion of like 12
year olds yeah but who did she [ __ ] to
get on the show
maybe she auditioned i don't know i did
check my own uh misogyny though because
i was that kid when britney spears was
dating justin timberlake i'm like why
britney spears though
he's just the biggest pop star of that
year yeah exactly right as if justin was
gonna knock on my door and be like hey
you mari
wanna be my girlfriend and like who the
[ __ ] am i to be like why britney though
you know what has she got and so it made
me reflect on the time where i felt so
um i i don't know like possessive of of
somebody that that i found you know to
be like enamoring or whatever it is and
being like well why this person i'm like
you know what i get it i'm like y'all
y'all cool off and i'm like i'm like i'm
not stepping on your toes they're not my
boyfriends i have my own boyfriend who's
now my husband and he's like
cute
it's like i i i knew internally that
that wasn't the narrative and so for me
i was able to sleep at night but like i
don't know it took
it took a lot of years to go back to the
question it took a lot of years for me
to to jump ship because it's not that i
didn't believe in it and the numbers
clearly showed it
um
and and very shortly after i started
making more than i would as a ballet
dancer i was literally a starving artist
with ballet
and yet still i was
i was i don't know
it's nothing that i that i aspired to so
i think it was a lot harder for me to
jump ship and be like this is the thing
but it did open the doors of like oh i
can be other things and that was really
um
that was really powerful because i i
i think looking back it felt like i was
on track
for
some like somebody else's agenda with
ballet yeah and i think with smosh i
felt like i i grabbed the torch of
something that was already there and i
and i upheld it but in a lot of ways
both both felt like they were handed to
me and so you know i think i think with
acting
it feels like now i'm really starting
from the ground up and i'm making the
choice oh cool and and so it feels like
a completely
new venture and i'm really to your
credit though
um i actually think
everyone has a silver spoon
it just depends if they discover it or
not
you know i think it's easier to draw the
line where it's like obviously
my mom is my coach so i have a wealth of
knowledge so at the same time where
there's the benefits of that
there's also
the hardest childhood for anybody you
know like if your dad's michael jordan
or do you watch mma
so like could be imagine being the son
of khabib's dad right like you also have
the hardest childhood in the universe
where practice doesn't stop now yeah
seven days ago wrestling bears dude yeah
seven days worth of practice
probably wake you up at 2 am because you
didn't do good enough yesterday you got
to do it again you know so there's like
there's it's a double-edged sword but i
think um to your credit
to be able to up hold
and continually continuously still have
millions of views
you know on the channel or to not have
crumbled
under having a mom slash coach
that shows some sort of strength you
know because i feel like for me i think
everyone is uh is given a silver spoon
like for example like i have a crazy ass
mom
and if like and i think i'm lucky enough
where i have my silver spoon i think is
comedy right so i'm able to
see
situations
and make light of them and make it
enjoyable and tell a story where
everyone can
also
be entertained and relate
but if i didn't discover that that was
my silver spoon i think i would just
hate my mom and like
after i die and like let's see i go to
whatever heaven and i'm able to kind of
see in retrospect and i'm like oh my god
there's 20 silver spoons in front of me
i just didn't grab a single one of them
you know what i mean yeah so i do
because i think like yeah i think
whether people get like if they got beat
up as a kid some people go out and write
a book or some people get beat up and
they just stay down because they didn't
see it as a silver spoon they just saw
it as like a metal club that kept
whacking them over the head yeah i think
that's why that whole like wake up and
meditate and be grateful and write all
that
i think there's a lot of a little
validity to that um
because we can really boil it down and
get super basic and be like well what am
i really grateful for like uh what is
the silver spoon that i have and people
can really like pull back the layers and
be like well my silver spoon is that i
can wake up every morning and it could
really be that simple or that i can get
up and get out of my bed and literally
walk
you know there's some people out there
that can't do that so it's like we can
focus on that or we can just focus on
like oh [ __ ] okay this is i try and this
is really [ __ ] hard but i try not to
look at things as negative or positive i
just try to look at things for
um what they are and whatever lesson i
can take from it and that took a [ __ ]
long time and i'm still working on that
[ __ ] but like looking at things as as
like there is always a yin to a yang
there's always a positive to that
negative there's always um the
superpower or like or things that we're
good at we're also going to be really
bad at you know what i mean like you can
be a superly emotionally connected
person and make people feel really good
but because you're so emotional a lot of
things could could like um like bring
you down really quickly you know what i
mean so every positive has a negative um
and i think
you know we're kind of raised also to be
super humble so you're saying you know i
was given the silver spoon and cool like
it's cool that you're being humble that
way but like [ __ ] all that dude like
you know what i mean like [ __ ] all that
because it's like okay
back in the day nobody knew what the
[ __ ] youtube was nobody knew what the
[ __ ] youtube was gonna become
uh and we're talking about what 20
2007 2000 maybe even 13 and that's when
things were really picking up but like
for you a female to enter a gaming space
and be like oh i can compete and
audition for this [ __ ] massive empire
of a channel like that's not a [ __ ]
silver spoon dude you had to have like a
big dick and balls to like really do
that do you know what i mean like i
don't know any chick in my circle around
that time that was like
i'm going to enter a dude's space or
even dudes i think many people would
have crumbled like when when i first
started doing like sketch comedy with
joe
um i was like auditioning too just i was
like we don't know like youtube is such
a small bubble right i'm like i got to
play both i got i was doing stand-up
comedy i was auditioning to trying to
get into traditional hollywood we're
also doing skits on the side and i'm
like why doesn't marvel just give me a
chance you know and then i see and i see
our buddy simu
like he gets the chance
and
i'm like oh my god like all the press
conferences yes go to snl red carpets he
has to be bulletproof you know when they
ask him a question he has to turn on the
charm yep give very perfect quotable
sound bite responses that people can
take to [ __ ] entertainment variety
whatever they they write all those
things and i'm like i would have died
under that pressure i might have been
able to
have been the actor in the film but to
do all that other stuff
i would have crumbled and like if you've
seen 13 000 dislikes every week and
you're like [ __ ] it i'm gonna keep
flying down for two and a half years
that's crazy that is crazy i don't think
that's a silver spoon dude yeah
appreciate it
i still i still have a hard time like
being like
i did good yeah
yeah
it's a girl and you're [ __ ] like
you're a minority you know what i mean
like that on top of you being a female
so you're like a double [ __ ] minority
you're entering a very white space
as an asian and as a chick like that
shit's not easy you know what the [ __ ]
up part is though
i i feel like all of us minorities were
conditioned to think that that's normal
that you're the you're the token
it's like because like in anything that
we saw in media and stuff it's like okay
well there's one and then that's all you
ever expect you don't expect to be
you know three asians on on the power
rangers right there's like you can only
have one you can only have one otherwise
it becomes an asian show you can only
you can only have one black person
otherwise it becomes a black chicken
it's so funny it's so
ridiculous but we've we were conditioned
to think that that's normal even being a
woman
and and seeing a bunch of men around me
i've been conditioned to know that
that's normal and that's really [ __ ]
up because you see another chick like
what is this a chick show now
can i too
um and so it's like
when when i entered the space i honestly
didn't even think about it i didn't even
think in the dir in the in the range of
like i am going to make my space here it
became that thing because i'm like
whoa you guys aren't kidding there's no
one else here so i can carve out my
little corner and and carve out a niche
but when i went into it i think
i think the ballot i think ballet is the
complete opposite where it's a sea of
women and the men are treated as like oh
we got one we got one
how much do you want how much do we pay
you
do you want double what the women get
you'll get it
and that's that was the normal culture
and so when i went into gaming i was
like i just don't wanna
okay well i wanna double what the guys
get because there's not a lot of me
that's amazing and so it wasn't a thing
where it was me making a statement it
was just reversing what i always knew
was just like well
you take the commodity and you give them
more because there's not a lot of them
that's but my stupid ass would have been
like thank you for giving me the chance
i'll take nothing i'll take half yeah
it's okay just thank you for letting me
sit here that's dope yeah i mean it came
out of the deficit of the other way
right where it was just like i lost jobs
by by the end of my ballet career i lost
jobs because i demanded the same pay as
my as my male counterparts and so when
you take on jobs as a uh as an
independent contractor you can come with
a partner and so my partner would get
paid a certain amount and i would be
like hey is it okay if i ask for the
same we might lose this job and my
partner jenkins was awesome um very
established in the space and he's like
yeah ask for cool and so he was really
supportive and so um you know it's it
became a thing where it's just like yep
this is our rate and i
lost out on some business but for the
most part it was like
okay
that's funny just had to add yeah thank
you for being a [ __ ] strong female
for that [ __ ] i love it thanks i love it
thanks uh yeah i mean
it's it is
a lot of it is throwing spaghetti at the
wall and being like oh [ __ ] it's stuck
and like i think you know like in the in
the beginning of the space of like
youtube space and stuff like that i
think a lot of it was that especially
when you start to talk with brands and
stuff and you're like oh you're talking
to me
what do you want yeah and they're like
you know what do you want you're like
i want i want you give a ridiculous
thing yeah and they're like okay we're
like oh
yeah
you know so it was an exciting time back
then of like figuring it out yeah for
sure okay so kind of shifting a little
bit so
ballet um smosh and then at some point i
don't know the details of this so can't
wait to hear it you're like
i'll be on a reality channel and then
you got on [ __ ] survivor oh yeah
survivor that's amazing what's the what
the [ __ ] yeah what's the like process of
getting on that kind of show
so what made you want to go on a show
like that i got recruited to be on the
show sick the uh the the casting
director worked with two other people at
defy at the time um and put them on
amazing race
and so they were still friends with them
i would have loved to be on the amazing
race honestly um survival was red
survivor survivor was rad um
and my two friends uh came to me and
they're like hey do you would you
consider survivor and at the point i was
at a breaking point i i kept writing in
my journal i just want to log off like i
want i don't know if i want to quit
digital i don't know if i want to quit
youtube i just want a break i just want
to stop what did you want to break
i
i think i was
i was really really like just tired of
like numbers and algorithms and just
hearing it every single day and
um
i don't know i just wanted to kind of
like put a pause on things i think it
was 20
i want to say it was 2017. and it's
weird because now that i look back at it
it was like the height of a lot of
things we're doing great things at smosh
games um
but i think uh
it was it was eight years in at that
point or like seven years into being in
digital and before i was in digital like
i was very outdoorsy like i would i
would climb like 20 000 foot peaks and
stuff like that which one um i did
first one i did was kilimanjaro which is
kind of a hike
there's nothing crazy about that one um
but i did two months in south america
and i did a bunch of mountains in
bolivia
wow and uh yeah and so that that had
like ice climbing and stuff like that
and so
um i i would just be able to like
i don't know be off the grid and in that
in that year i think it was 2017. um i
was like i just want to be off the grid
i just want to leave i just want to like
just like log off for a bit and then
this opportunity came they're like hey
do you want to do survivor i'm like how
long do i have to be offline for they're
like seven weeks and i was like i'm in
how do i audition and so i i auditioned
for it it was a millennials versus gen x
season and so it was all about like okay
millennials you don't know how to talk
to people what's that like
you're you're you know like you're the
life of a gamer all you do is talk to
talk to people over a headset and you
know live a life inside of a digital
realm how are you going to survive
talking to real people on an island i'm
like
i don't think
you i i'm like i get the box you want to
put me yeah they're just trying to make
a show yeah yeah and i'm like i i
understand the archetypes but
honestly i was really geeking out on the
production process of it because of
so so many elements of it are exactly
what you said trying to make a show
right so finding the right characters
and finding the right personality types
to make you know
oil and oil and water right and just
finding as many
opposite characters as possible to make
people absolutely blow up and you just
see it in front of you
um
do they direct it do they go like hey
uh
that guy has a peanut allergy sprinkle
some peanuts
oh definitely don't do that but they do
observe
and and so it's like
before the show they take extensive
personality quizzes and personality like
um
i can't even call it a quiz it's not a
buzzfeed question like survey almost
yeah it's like a psycho psychoanalysis
with a psychiatrist and so they know all
of your triggers
and so you know like
you know let's say my trigger is um uh
people who don't cooperate like in a
group project right and and i've ranted
to the psychologist about about like oh
i just don't like it when people don't
play their part or whatever
and if there was a moment where somebody
was sitting for a long time like on on
the uh island
at the end of the day they'd be like how
do you feel about so-and-so you know
they didn't really pull their part you
know
how do you feel about that so they know
exactly what to to ask
to get reactions out of you um and so in
some ways i in some ways i wish i didn't
know that because it was so obvious in
black and white to me that that was the
deal and so i'm like well if i didn't
know that maybe i would have more fun
but i was just kind of geeking out on
like oh like they would ask me a
question and be like oh i know why they
asked me that question oh
do you think it's because you came from
the digital realm where like we see a to
z we're almost involved in a to z so
we're not just like talent so to speak
so you kind of already know why things
are being done yeah yeah absolutely
and then seeing like the camera guys and
stuff was really cool because when when
they're on their off season from
survivor they're doing documentaries and
stuff like that and they're like
documenting wildlife or they're they're
in uh like war-torn countries and things
like that so they come from like real
documentarian backgrounds so
these there were workhorses they were
sprinting for hours on sand with huge
cameras you know like they would take a
tumble backwards somersault with their
camera and still have it locked
shot like i was just like oh those guys
are dope
yeah it was really nice
pay attention yeah yeah she's about to
eat a bug i need to interview you right
after this yeah i don't think that was a
very good subject for the show i really
really don't i don't think it was a good
subject for the show i don't think that
i would give the reactions that they
would want because i i know too much of
like what a reaction looks like on
television or like on a screen and so
i i don't think that i would be good
television in that sense i'm just too
meta when that when it comes to that but
i had seven weeks off and it was
wonderful
that's sick it was a craziest thing you
had to do
um
i didn't have to do too many i wasn't on
the island for very long um so what
happens is
as soon as you're kicked off of the show
then they keep you quarantined until the
whole show is filmed so there are no
spoilers if i went home then people
around me would know for sure that i i
went home early so you're like stuck in
a hotel or something or yeah australia
for like five weeks amazing
on their dime so but no no phone no
phone no email amazing
release anything exactly yeah so so
i feel the the worst part about it is
knowing that peter my husband was back
at home
this like thought that i was starving on
an island
and that i'm cold and like he knew that
there was a tropical storm we were the
first uh
uh people on an island who had to get
evacuated because the tropical storm was
so bad
um and
it was like a cat five or something like
that was ridiculous the the lightning
was like less than a mile away by the
time that we were pulled off um so it
was that was like that was the hardest
sitting through a storm and and i don't
i think i've been colder but i've never
been that cold for that period of time
i think we were sitting in rain like in
puddles for like 12 hours oh [ __ ] yeah
that sucks and our shelter was a piece
of [ __ ] and that
got ruined that night was it a shelter
that you guys had to build yeah we built
it it was a piece of [ __ ] it was
terrible
it's it's amazing that no one got like
literally like skewered by the bamboo
sticks because we built it like like it
was like
[ __ ] like bamboo lodge like this is
the most millennial thing right like to
make it look like
like this
20 like 10 person hut that we could all
sleep in it together so we laid across
these bamboo like crisscross do you guys
have experience did someone like
know what they're doing or everyone just
kind of brainstormed like i think this
is what we need to do no one had real
experience i think all of us had a
youtube education and watched a few of
those like um
you know those like those builder shows
where there's like people who go into
like nature and they build a cabin or
whatever we all had that education which
is not a real education at all yeah
yeah and so the night of that storm we
were all packed in there not all of us a
lot of us were packed in there but not
all of us i know i wasn't in there um
and the whole thing broke and there were
just shards
just sticking out like
freaking
skewers
no one got hurt thankfully but that that
kicked us all out of our shelter and so
we were just sitting outside and like
at one point i know i
became hysterical like i would just look
up at the sky and i'd be just laughing
because it seemed fake it was like
like
somebody had a weather machine and was
just pushing random ass buttons is what
it felt like though like there's no
[ __ ] way that we were out here and
there's lightning that you can see and
here at the same time which is really
bad there was no delay oh i'm like this
producer is off to the side going yes
yes juicy parts you know what's weird
they don't talk to you they sit there
and even at nighttime they have one red
light and they sit in a chair like this
and your tent or not in your tent your
like shelter wherever you sleep is like
right around the and they just watch for
moments and there's a camera on sticks
that just sits there and they just and
like you try to make chitchat like i was
like a i don't know like an [ __ ] and
i'd try to jim helper all the time and
be like
you know
i'm sure by like day 49 they'll give you
a smirk but on like the first couple of
weeks they give you nothing i'm just
like hey
they're like stop monkey yeah we're just
watching you suffer i want the suffer
face on yeah not this clown [ __ ] they're
like we've had 33 seasons of this we
don't want to see those
yeah was that um an entrance or was that
like a taste of you going oh [ __ ]
obviously it's not acting because it's
like real life especially you saying
like no one had any like intervention or
anything
um was that like a little bug for you
where you're like oh [ __ ] i like this
feeling
no
i i didn't see it any different as what
we were already creating at smosh to be
honest it was it was
real life sort of uh
like
it was just reality it was just what you
do in real life and and you know how you
go through things when things are thrown
at you
um
and i think with smosh like we would do
such off the wall bat [ __ ] crazy stuff
we would do obstacles and things like
that we would dunk ourselves in water
and we would we would eat ridiculous
things that a lot of it didn't surprise
me i was just like oh this is just this
when you throw a lot of money at it
and i'm like it it didn't it didn't seem
as as
big of a thing as it would if i didn't
come from like that production
background yeah um
i think if anything it made me not want
to do reality television again because
i'm just like oh i see it for what it is
and it doesn't add anything for me it
doesn't give me anything um i know i'm
not wired in a way where
i get so excited when i see a camera
that i'll do
off the wall [ __ ] just to do it i'll do
it if it's part of the production i'll
do it knowing that there is a storyline
and an end goal but i won't do it just
to do it and i think for reality tv
that's what they want yeah i just want
people to just be
uncalculated and just operate as humanly
as possible and i'm like huh i
calculate too much
for there for them to make good quality
television out of it i see yeah so where
did that come about then that
calculation uh the the urge to go oh i'm
gonna pursue acting oh
god
it's still such a scary thing because i
feel like acting in my mind in my world
it is the same thing as like i want to
go to space i want to be an astronaut
you know it's like it's like the the
thing when
i see my kid's self saying it and being
like oh that's cool that's cute you know
you you go do whatever you want not
parallel to space and acting yeah
the fact that it just seems like such a
huge jump from
what can be realistic in my world like i
i think that it's such a huge pipe dream
that it was always really scary for me
to even put it out there and so even
though i had aspirations
um to be an actor and and at the at the
core of it it's just to be an artist and
i think that goes back to ballet and
that's what i really was in the in at
the core of it um but acting you know
because acting comes with the whole
outer layer of
celebrity and fame and all that stuff
yeah like i made it into this really
really big thing in my mind of like i'll
never be able to attain it
but
now that i'm in school and i've kind of
stripped away all of that other stuff
and see it for the art that it is i'm
like oh i really want to do this
um and and i want to put the time and
the energy and the effort into it and
and work
from it like from the ground up for it
um but it's a little like scary to say
like i want to be an actor i i still
feel
eyeballs go like oh you want to be an
actor you know like i feel
i feel the judgment like you're like
casting director around you or or
something of like oh why like why why
are you
able to or why are you why do you feel
like you can you know and it's that's my
own judgment
like turning back on me and just kind of
ripping myself apart um but now i feel
like i'm armored with understanding that
better what when did you decide
that you wanted to be an actor and like
how long how much of school have you
done for it
um i think
i think the pandemic is really when i
i made the decision i'd been telling
peter like for years i'm like okay i
really if i'm gonna if i'm gonna act i
want to do it in the way that makes
sense for me and that's from for me i'm
just like it's a lab coat effect for me
it's like i feel like i need to have
like earned it and earned the stripes
for me to be like i am this thing
it's like the ballet approach probably
it's the ballet approach what is the
acting version of putting books on my
knees yes i need to go do those yeah
yeah and like that's what makes sense
for me and like i felt like a fraud in
gaming until i hit my 10-year mark and
i'm like okay now i can say like i think
i've got authority in in gaming you know
up until then i feel like i'm like well
you know i'm in i'm in the space and i'm
trying to figure it out and i'm trying
to do the thing but it took 10 years for
me to be like you know what i
think
we made some impacts in some places i
think
i know what i'm talking about you know
and and there were patches of me feeling
that way but like for me to to just go
like you know what i'm proud of me for
doing that it took 10 years um
and so i i don't know maybe it's just a
10-year journey for me for all these
things how long have you started this
whole acting oh training process i am so
there's a conservatory program that
always sounds crazy it does
conservatory
yeah you have to say with a british
accent otherwise it's not real yeah um
i'm in my fifth semester for the
conservatory [ __ ] yeah and so that
sounds crazy too
so i've done it five times
a year and
some change is where i'm at is it out
here over there it's in l.a but because
of the pandemic it's been on zoom oh
okay i'm like you're going back to l.a
like you're still i am though i am gonna
be going back and forth um as soon as
coveted restrictions are are better we
were supposed to be in school this week
but omicron is so bad right now um that
they had to cancel but
are you doing scenes over zoom up until
this time we had been yeah whoa what is
that like that's correct
it's very it is very weird you don't
you don't get the same like it's the
same way as if we were doing this
interview
over zoom let's suck
and then you freeze you're just like
it's like hello are you there yeah
hello
and then in some ways like you like we
would we would stop talking we'd say
thank you goodbye and then in some ways
we'd be like yeah that was good like
that was
that was you know we had a great talk
and we'd probably have the same
conversations but
it is so different
it's just
feeling another person in the room you
know and just having real life eye
contact as opposed to me looking at a
screen this way and you looking at me
looking at you yeah you know it's like
probably like this
yeah and it's like i know you're looking
at me here
but you're not looking at me yeah and
it's like i can't imagine how difficult
that is to process for like kids going
through school right now where it's just
you see the eyeballs back at you but
they're not looking at you they're
looking at a screen
a screen version
yeah a screen version of you and so uh
you know i i think there's elements of
understanding that um that's so hard but
it makes you listen more
yeah because even like practicing lines
or doing lines with like a casting
director right you're like oh no save me
save me
you're like [ __ ] that's all i get like
how do i how do i react to that you know
you got to make something no no all
right thanks uh we'll call you you're
like [ __ ]
you weren't convincing as a drowning
victim
i've never been to anything like that
like i don't want to pursue acting or
any of that but like um i feel like i
got some sort of insight watching uh
what's that oh god land la la land yeah
have you watched it i haven't watched oh
my god it's so [ __ ] good for so many
reasons yeah you should really watch it
well okay so
there's a there's a scene in there where
the main character
she's she wants to become an actress she
wants to become a famous actress so you
see her uh prepping for her audition so
she has to wear you know the waitress
outfit because that's the character she
wants to the role she wants to get and
then she goes into the waiting room and
literally everyone looks exactly like
her and then she's in front of the
casting director she's doing her scene
and she like starts bawling and you can
feel her acting and she's so good and
then within like seconds they're like
okay thank you and she's like oh
like she has to like pull herself out of
like this really deep place she like
just put herself in to be convincing and
they have to kick her out yeah she has a
scene where like i think maybe a family
member died or something and she found
out over the phone
so she's crying and then literally like
a production
assistant is coming taking lunch orders
oh y'all have the salami
and she's [ __ ] like oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
you know that's nuts yeah i'll take the
salami all right and i'll talk to you
later and then it's like what the [ __ ]
is so crazy i i think that's what i like
about the school that i'm in which is
the method school where it's like they
they
they
really emphasize that it should be like
a muscle like you're training for the
gym like you're training for
whatever it is like your your morning
exercise or whatever it is where it's
just like you go to that place but you
don't stay there it should be a thing
where it's like if they're like if
they're like okay thank you and you're
like
right it's the same way where it's like
i mean i don't know anything about power
lifting but it's like you you power lift
you do the thing and then you walk away
you did the thing
and so so so that you can get to that
emotional place but not sit in it and
true
i like that thank you you put that into
perspective because yeah definitely when
you gear up to like hit a personal right
i'm gonna kill someone yeah you have to
go i don't need to kill anybody yeah
like i have to get in that space you
know like i'm shaking the [ __ ] bar
like i'm making sure it even hurts a
little bit because i want that
aggression and then once i rack it i'm
like oh man that was really good and i'm
like over it like i'm not trying to
fight people yeah yeah okay so
that's what they try to
how do you teach that though
practice
and and that's that's the thing where it
comes to that's what i do comes down to
like yeah where it's just like you
practice and you practice so that it
becomes
that that thing and it's like you find
the triggers like i have this this uh
notebook of like triggers right where
it's just like a certain material will
make me
feel
a certain way
make me remember a certain thing and
it's not always sad it's it can be
euphoric and happy and things like that
do you do that before scenes you're like
oh i need my uh she has like my rabbit
rabbit's tail just for this one yeah
yeah
or you or or if you don't have it on
hand then you you remember the feeling
of it so much that it can take you there
but it's if you think about it like
everything that we say and everything
that we do there's always an intention
behind it you know it's like
the the way i'm talking right now
there's probably an intention of of why
my cadence is here as opposed to up here
right now you know it's like there's
always a reason why we do stuff and and
when you rip apart a script then you
realize like the humanity of all the
lines that you're reading because that's
a human person going through all these
layers of feelings and that's why
they're saying this there's a reason why
they say this it's not just pulling
random words out of their asses and so i
don't know for me i think it's it's
helped me kind of
step back and realize just uh like the
beauty of like being human and all that
stuff that's awesome
that's great is have you looked for any
places out here or do they all just suck
um your faces
i haven't just because i am fully
drinking the kool-aid of my school right
now
um and it's like it is the only are they
the best of the best they are
for the method it's a conservatory yeah
it's an institute of theatre and film
where's the skull
on fairfax and melrose
honestly i love it for that quality of
it
yeah
um
there's there's a few reasons why i went
with it from like a
technical version of like it's a edu so
it's an accredited like um
uh institute as opposed to it being a
dot-com and for me that was important
where i'm just like well they're not
just like doing it to like she'll cash
um but you you do receive some sort of
like accredited education and you get
the asian parent approval
yeah i mean i i
i i'm past
trying to receive it i see because i i
don't think it's going to
be the one that i want what if you
she lands a role as a believer yeah yeah
ballet movie swan you think your mom
would be like
you know you know
this is the most ridiculous part with
like
i think they are proud for what makes
sense to them so
when when uh
uh my husband i invested into uh space
station gaming which is an esports
company it was is a big deal especially
like in the gaming realm like me coming
from an influencer in gaming and
somebody who just plays video games to
being a co-owner of an esports by the
way team thank you that was like it was
a big thing
and i told my parents and they're like
okay cool cool cool cool
all this press came out they're like
cool cool cool cool that's whatever and
then it came out in japanese ah there it
is
and they're like oh my gosh it wasn't it
was on yahoo japan
this is a big deal and i'm like
yup i you know i'm like i'm glad that
that
now it's in a it's in a way that you
understand it and it's like i'll do i'll
do things that to me in my world are a
big deal but like something like being
on a twitch billboard in times square
that i got zero dollars for they're like
oh my god i'm like because to them
that's success yeah that's b-roll mom
yeah
yeah it's just like i'm like yeah it's
up there but it's like it it didn't you
know i don't know if that
moves the ticker forward yeah yeah i it
does zero for my bank account in the
immediate in that
you know immediate like
short term yeah long term maybe because
someone someone else will see and be
like well she's been on billboards or
whatever but i've never put it on a
[ __ ] billboard put me on a billboard
please yeah
it's not all cracked up to be you walk
out and you're like holy [ __ ] and then
after 30 seconds you're like
i mean there's a lot of other billboards
you know that's the person that's been
on a [ __ ] billboard
not yet not yet guys
no i'm kidding i'm kidding i think it's
super rad
um
so what is the dream right now with
acting
it seems like that's like the thing here
yeah
i don't have a set
like dream like i i wish it could be
like i want to be in a marvel movie i
don't necessarily you just like the art
form of it so far yeah i i want to be in
a my dream is to be in a substantially
um like well-written
um
piece of
piece of film okay who's the director
who's the writer here oh jeez i'd love
to do an aaron sorkin um
i i don't i i actually don't know who
wrote oh you like some serious [ __ ] huh
i do like serious [ __ ] and i think
that's like um
the dichotomy of like being like a clown
like on the internet eating [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] yeah going into slime yeah
because like that is that is one part of
me like that is absolutely still a part
of me and an animated
portion of me is still me and then
there's this other part where is like it
is the pretentious bun head artist you
know like
who who
cares about certain
things done a certain way and like being
technically
uh
proficient and things like that and that
is another part of me and i'm like i've
always had a very hard time matching the
two
um
but i think i just need to like
understand that that's two parts of me
i'm still a clown but i still really
want to
deep like dig deep into
i don't know that's fair all the icky
[ __ ]
i think we all have multiple
personalities but i think um
that i mean as of recent was always kind
of kooky to say that you can be
aggressive to say that you can be super
nurturing to say that you can be a
[ __ ] boss ass person to be a clown to
be a baby like we possess all of that
yeah but i think as of recent people are
finally like accepting and seeing it so
i think what you're feeling is
absolutely the human experience is there
a trajectory of someone
that's an actor actress or whatever that
you're like
that'd be cool to like have something
similar to that um
that's a really good question
um
i think
i don't i don't know i i still get
really hung up on like the trajectory
from going digital to traditional
because i still think that there was
like this hard drawn line of like
at what point do we start blurring it
and in a lot of ways sometimes we do but
i don't know if hollywood's really ready
yeah i don't think we're there yet i
don't think so it's like we're not there
yet i haven't seen one hit here that has
been a hit here yeah i've seen more hits
here go
yeah over here we've seen a lot of our
colleagues have shows and specials and
movies and written and we're like
and also
a lot of people aren't doing the work
you're doing too five semesters you know
like one of my uh comedy teachers he was
one of the main writers on key and peel
even on mad tv
and uh he helped wright get out
and um
he's going into the movie space
and i thought it would be like silver
spoon and he goes no he goes in terms of
someone to write a special for
the super bowl
or for the grammys or someone needing a
monologue for snl they'll call me like
that because they know i can crush 30
minutes one hour whatever right but he's
like when you go into the movies he's
like even i have a crossover problem so
he's like it's not just a like new media
into hollywood it's just everything that
isn't that craft is gonna have a
crossover problem yeah wow that's crazy
i never thought that'd be like that i
think there's very few people who've
done it and and people who have done it
did it early like donald glover is a
good example right i forgot about it
he's also one of those guys i think that
has been training and he's so he's like
a trained individual like batch is one
of those guys too yeah you know he has
like a masters in theater and film and
yeah he came in this the youtube space
already yeah so there's people that have
already been training and they're just
shooting their shot in different
platforms throwing the spaghetti as mari
calls it yeah so those guys i think
like i think uh jimmy tatro is one of
those guys
so i think it's easier for those but
like for someone that's like up here
that hasn't had that specific training
we haven't seen one just yet yeah it's
re it's really hard it it in a lot of
ways it feels like you know like um
like like when you start like wanting to
change something about yourself but like
your friend group like like if i started
wearing i don't know um like
hot pink everywhere yeah and then all my
friend groups would be like what's up
with that you know
like
what's this new thing you're doing
that's not who i know yeah and i'm like
it's a new thing just let it be
and they're like nah no you you you
don't wear that
but then but then if you go into a new
friend group and and they're like oh
that that's that's mario she wears pink
she loves pink looks great and and
that's you get a fresh like slate
we don't get to do that as digital
creators because we have like
a track record that people can pull up
and be like nah you're this person
you're branded
yeah and and i think for for most people
i will always be wacky smosh games mari
for like the rest of time no matter what
i do
um and i don't think that's bad i i
think that it's it's more so of like the
people who hire me how they see me yeah
because how how an audience member sees
me is like that's
they get to keep that i don't get to
dictate to them
how they should see me yeah but i think
for the people who hire me i think it's
important that they see other sides
and right now i'm racking my brain i'm
like
how do i
how do i do that
well good thing right like you said
you're calculated so i think calculating
where it is you want to head and who you
want to be and who you want to portray
in terms of characters and and all of
that i think i think you're already well
off to a good start right because you're
just saying like i'm already naturally
calculated so i think it's a matter of
like picking those roles or those um
scenes or movies or whatever yeah you're
like wait i'm not gonna do the wacky
comedy stuff because that's not where
i'm trying to go i'm gonna start posting
aaron sorkin scenes
right little 36 60 seconds that's what
happened to uh ali maki right uh i think
she that's how she got discovered for
toy story like being a voice for that oh
really am i making that up i think no
she was established before yeah okay
yeah she's been acting for a while 10 15
years maybe i like read a headline and
was like because of that youtube that i
guess it kind of like cemented something
or yeah yeah i can understand it i could
be making some [ __ ] up yeah we can uh we
could take that out or we're not taking
a [ __ ] out or it could be like media
just hijacking a random sound bite to
make it sexy true like you know what
like simu it's like oh that one tweet
that i might right now [ __ ]
audition
seven thousand times in 2017 he told me
like he had to like do these crazy
backflips and still like i'm like it's
not a tweet
it never is the big break never is that
it's literally anyone that has like made
it successful in anything takes minimum
minimum 10 years but we all like the
that narrative it's the american idol
narrative right where it's just like you
just go on a show and you win and you
become kelly clarkson don't say kelly
clarkson i was hoping you would not say
[ __ ] kelly she's the only one that i
don't
know
who's another one carrie underwood is
that another one no i think she's been
in the or maybe don't know i literally
don't know another i don't hate kelly
clarkson i just can't deal with her
voice i'm sure she's a sweet lady she's
an amazing singer she's an amazing
singer but i just can't
i just
can't every [ __ ] christmas song that
kelly clarkson is in i'm like let's
change the [ __ ] channel and i'd love
christmas but i'm like kelly clarkson
why
but anyway amazing anyway on that note
mario i want to say thank you so much
this was such a cool conversation i felt
like i got so much closer to you like
you're just rad dude and like
and like um you got to give yourself
more credit like but if you don't it's
all good we'll give it to you whatever
the imposter syndrome is happy guys
really man but i love what you've done
for chicks like i look at you and i'm so
glad that you're in this space and you
continue to to enter into different
spaces because we need more chicks like
you dude like you don't you don't see
your
your uh physical exterior or your
background
uh whether that's your ethnicity or any
of that as a crutch and you're always
just like well i just want to move
whatever's in here and in here and like
i'm just going to keep moving forward
and i [ __ ] love that so keep doing
you do appreciate you yeah thank you so
much this is a delight yay
well thank you guys so much for watching
and we'll catch you guys next time bye